50 years ago the moon was at the center
of the Cold War America was in a space
race with the Russians lives were lost
as NASA tested new technology victory
took extraordinary human endeavor and a
perilous descent to the lunar surface
mark t-minus 10 minutes and Counting
t-minus 10 we're aiming for our plan
liftoff at 32 minutes past the hour this
is Kennedy launch control I think you
have to take risk in exploration would
we take the same level of risk now as
they did back then
probably not they decided a long time
they were going to do it
now's the day that they just got to get
through that stage not to they would
probably rather the world wasn't
watching them we're on time at the
present time for our plan liftoff of 32
minutes past the hour you're just
guessing with what you need to do and
the main thing is I don't want to trip
up in front of all these people watching
I then walk in a line and I go to wave
to the cameras there and I've got to get
my boots up on these steps to get into
the bus so you're just getting on with
that thing although it's mundane because
you're just you're just walking in a
space suit you're just aware that the
world's watching you and the astronauts
launch operations manager Paul's only
wish the crew on the launch team's
behalf good luck and Godspeed I'll still
go at this time Neil Armstrong reported
back when he received the good wishes
thank you very much we know it will be a
good flight
[Music]
t-minus one minute 35 seconds on the
Apollo mission the flight to land first
men on the moon all indications coming
in to the control center at this time
indicate we are go one minute 25 seconds
and counting
30 seconds and counting
astronauts report it feels good t-minus
25 seconds 20 seconds and counting
t-minus 15 seconds guidance is internal
12 11 10 9 ignition sequence starts 6 5
4 3 2 1 zero all engines on liftoff we
have a liftoff 32 minutes past the hour
let's talk on Apollo 11
it's different it's lumpy and bumpy
during a lot you can't you can never
really experienced that in a simulator
to jettison you get the central core
that's jettisoned and then there's a
split second before the next stage kicks
in so you get this kind of jerky launch
profile and you hear the bangs reaching
25,000 miles an hour the Saturn 5 rocket
propelled Neil Armstrong Buzz Aldrin and
Michael Collins towards the moon a
three-day journey in zero gravity
feeling weightless is the most I mean
natural relaxing feeling you can imagine
I just forgot what it's like to sit down
or to stand up it just is so natural
it's as though we've we've been born in
space looking out of the window and
going hey you know that's pretty cool
I'm really here this is actually
fantastic that would have been an
amazing sight for Neil and Buzz it would
be a fraud 13 minute descent to the
surface in the lunar lander codenamed
eagle Michael Collins orbited the moon
alone hoping for their safe return
[Music]
okay retro go I don't go guys go control
go don't come go just say no he can't
know Sergent go I'm Tom work overrun
bunting okay we're off to a good start
blade cool he thinks you're a little
just long downrange that's right I think
we confirm that we confirm that Roger
then the flight computer the crew
depended on had a meltdown overloaded by
data it sounded an error code scratching
their heads I think this is one that
they hadn't actually rehearsed before
they weren't really ready for this
particular LARM and the Christian
Mission Control he could hear in Mission
Control that they were trying to
logically work through all it's just it
seems to happen when we've got this
particular thing but just as they sold
one problem they encountered another
Eagle was running dangerously low on
fuel everybody hang tight seven and a
half minutes
he sent to co-current didn't want to I
think the field was kind of sloshing
about of it wasn't it so they they were
the sensors weren't necessarily giving
the an accurate reading to do have to
rely to a certain point on what what
information you're being given and you
know that if it's wrong you know bottom
line is you'll die overall they thought
the probability of success was maybe 50
50 and that tremendous risk of the
landing the first landing the alarm
computer alarms going off all of these
moments of excitement maybe
nervousness back in Mission Control yet
buzz Neil they just seem incredibly calm
through it all is that bit about
physically seeing a certain part of the
moon's surface and deciding you know
that's a bit rocky I'm gonna go
somewhere else we've heard from Mission
Control have they were looking at their
heart rates and so on and Armstrong's
heart rate was higher than all dreams I
think understanding stay so yeah I'm on
strong was just so desperate to get this
right
but equally not wanting to rush it is
now just a minutes worth of fuel left in
the tank forward 30 feet down to a nap
from that make that out or forward drip
into the right little
[Applause]
I'm back right okay engine stop we copy
it down and off they made it with just
18 seconds to spare the eagle has landed
rocket wing tranquility we can't be on
the ground you got a bunch of guys about
to turn blue we're breathing again
thanks a lot little surprise that Neil
and Buzz couldn't sleep as planned and
instead immediately prepared to take
their historic steps on the moon last
step was about three and a half feet
from the surface and we're somewhat
concerned that we might have difficulty
and re-entering the limb at the end of
our activity period so we practice
[Music]
very very fine-grained as you get glued
to it it is almost like a powder out man
grapevine I'm gonna step off the LEM
[Music]
oh now we have Americans on the moon
I've never tried interpolation
I remember seeing these images I didn't
really understand the magnitude of the
event until I was older I do remember
thinking I want to be just like them
[Music]
so many people have done so much to give
us this opportunity to place this
American flag on the surface immediate
was one of those prouder moments of my
life
Columbia Columbia Houston they left over
I guess you're about the only person
around it doesn't have TV coverage of
the food beautiful Mike really is
kangaroo hop that works but it seems our
your forward ability is not quite as
good which get rather tiring after Neil
and the President of the United States
is in his office now and would like the
fact you were go ahead mr. president
this is Houston out I'm talking to you
by telephone from the oval room at the
White House I just can't tell you to
redouble our efforts to bring peace and
tranquility to earth
it's an extraordinary moment which
brought the world together and I think
we don't have so many of those moments
and I think we have to reflect on that
and think about that and dream of the
future we shouldn't just stop because
we've reached the moon there's always a
next step and next goal that we can
achieve I hope that my generation and
younger people we have our own Apollo 11
moments and maybe see the first person
step on the Martian surface Mars and
perhaps one day beyond but Apollo 11
will remain one of the most significant
events in human history the first time
we stepped onto an alien world
[Music]
you
[Music]